All right, let's have some fun.
We've talked before about how Donald Trump's
English language skills aren't the best.
Donald Trump is a native English speaker.
Donald Trump doesn't speak any other language
that I'm aware of, but he doesn't read period.
His reading comprehension as a result is visibly
compromised when he has to read anything other
than the sort of lightest material.
We all know that that's not new.
Yesterday Donald Trump met with French president
Emmanuel Macron on the sidelines, or I guess
we would say in advance of the NATO summit
that's taking place in the United Kingdom.
And I realized when I was watching the video,
McCrone can better express himself in English,
which is Trump's native and only language
and not the native language for a manual McCrone
then Donald Trump himself can express himself.
So I'm not literally saying McCrone speaks
better English than Trump.
I am saying McCrumb seems to be better able
to do sort of hypothetical multi-dimensional
thinking out loud than Donald Trump.
McCrone is better able to express ideas in
more nuanced ways than Donald Trump, even
in his non native language of English.
Uh, in this video you are going to see Donald
Trump first talk about capturing ISIS fighters
in Syria.
Sort of stumbling around.
It's unclear what point Trump is trying, trying
to make.
At one point he asks McCrone, Hey, do you
want some nice ISIS fighters?
It's all very weird.
It's not making any sense.
And then you'll see the French president take
control of the situation.
Taking, uh, talking more seriously about the
reality that despite what Donald Trump might
say, ISIS has not been defeated.
And you will see that even in the English
as a second language spoken by Emanuel McCrone,
he elucidates more thoughtfulness and nuance
than Donald Trump could ever hope to when
talking about this issue.
Let's take a look.
If you're watching, you will notice Trump
doing this thing where when Trump feels emasculated
or upset at what someone next to him is saying
or doing, he will sort of look down and have
a particular look on his face.
You're going to see Trump do it.
Uh, and then after Donald Trump, uh, when
Donald Trump gets a chance to talk again,
he has nothing left to do but to just attack
McCrone by calling it a non-answer merely
because Donald Trump doesn't like it.
Let's take a look a lot to, uh, find and see
in this clip
we have a, a tremendous amount of captured
fighters, ISIS fighters over in Syria and
uh, they're all under lock and key, but many
of them, France, many are from Germany and
many are from UK.
They're mostly from Europe and some of the
countries are agreeing.
I have not spoken to the president about that.
Uh, would you like some nice ISIS fighters?
I can give them to.
You can take everyone you want.
Let's be serious at the very last.
Number five is governs the grown.
I have to fight for this.
I mean from Thea from me, right in the region.
Four and five.
It's coming from Europe.
But this is a tiny minor repeal.
The old level of them we have and the rigid
and I think number one priority because it's
not finished, it's to get rid of it.
And this always groups.
This is our number one priority and it's not,
you're dumb.
I'm sorry to say that.
Yes, you still have fighters in this region,
in [inaudible] and now in Iraq and more and
more and to hold the civilization of the region
makes the situation more difficult to fix
the situation against.
Secondly, some of this foreign fighters are
being injured in Iraq because of the Dean's
personality.
Yet as they act in the very rigid and we would
have a case by case we haven't met Italian
approach or children already organized and
we will have a case by case approach.
But for me, the very first objective in the
region is to finish war against ISIS and,
and, and don't, don't make any mistake.
You'll number one problem on those are foreign
fighters.
This is the ISIS fighter.
Be directly and you'll have more and more
than fighters due to the situation today.
This is why he's a great politician, cause
that was one of the greatest non-answers I've
ever heard.
And that's okay.
You can tell that when Donald Trump isn't
pleased and he feels emasculated, he does
that thing where he looks down at the ground
while the other person is talking.
And then of course Trump just has to attack
McCrone rather than addressing the substance,
which he either didn't understand or probably
wasn't listening to because McCrone did talk
for 90 straight seconds there.
Once again, we started the show today with
Donald Trump being the embarrassment that
he is and being made fun of by world leaders.
Video of Emmanuel McCrone and Boris Johnson
and Justin Trudeau just laughing at Trump
because Trump is literally the laughingstock
of the world right now and it's embarrassing
and it's sad.
And here it is.
Once again, Donald Trump, embarrassing the
United States on the world stage getting called
out on his lies in real time by the French
president Emmanuel Macron.
But it's not going to hurt Trump very much
because Trump is, we'll see this.
They'll also zone out during those 90 seconds
that Macron is speaking.
They will just see Trump say, look at that
non-answer comment and think, wow, what is
zinger? Trump really got him.
Trump is strong and Trump won.
Can you imagine?
Would you like some nice ISIS fighters? Trump
asks McCrone when you see Trump sitting next
to real diplomats like Emmanuel McCrone, it
doesn't mean you agree with everything McCrone
stands for or his policy or whatever, but
when you see Trump next to a real diplomat,
it shows you how in over his head.
Donald Trump is a, particularly at these international
events sometimes to Americans.
When Trump is with a world leader who doesn't
speak English and you have to go through live
translation, the difference in intelligence
in knowledge intact in cleverness, it's not
noticeable because of that language barrier,
because of the fact that we're going through
live translation to hear what the other world
leader is saying.
When the other world leaders speaks English,
even accented English, learned as a second
language, as is the case with the French president.
The credibility gap, the critical thinking
gap, the knowledge gap, it becomes unavoidably
clear.
And that's what happened there in that video.
Trump totally out of his element, Trump totally
out of his league.
And the next question is what will come of
the NATO summit in the UK?
And I got a lot of emails about this.
By the time you listen to today's show or
watch clips from today's show, we may know
what the dynamic was at the main meetings
of the NATO summit.
Of course, it's five, six hours, uh, ahead
of the East coast.
They're in the UK.
And as I mentioned earlier, a lot of caution
being taken to prevent Donald Trump from just
ruining the meetings.
Donald Trump has been very critical, even
coming from a place of ignorance, but very
critical of the relationship of different
countries to NATO, of NATO in and of itself.
As I mentioned earlier, Emmanuel McCrone playing
a little bit of toddler reverse psychology
with Donald Trump and getting Donald Trump
to defend NATO merely by making sort of narrow
and specific critique of NATO.
There is fear.
There is fear among Trump staffers and among
other world leaders and their staffers of
what is Donald Trump's presence at this summit
going to do.
We will cover it tomorrow.
We will see ultimately what comes of it.
Uh, let me know what you predict will happen.
Maybe you'll already know, uh, by the time
today's episode is published, we'll talk about
it more tomorrow.